et sur la forme moi j'ai été extrêmement
choqué par exemple du spectacle offert
sur les marches de l'elysée
le soir de la fête de la musique toute
chose avec ce tee shirt de d'un rappeur
avec un slogan provocateur d'immigrés
doit répéter parce que je les lisais les
l'elysée de gaulle notamment appel à une
certaine solennité on ne banalise pas
les lieux de la république
voilà on ne les abîmes pas je le dis
très clairement ça a besoin de l'ubs le
relais de cette image cette confusion
des genres elle a légitimement choqués
beaucoup de français on avait vu et
j'avais pu le l'apprécier d'ailleurs
personnellement emmanuel macron essayer
de représidentialiser la fonction
élyséenne
notamment il y avait des symboles
versailles le louvre la présidence
jupitérienne et puis là on entendu nous
allons y label national en session c'est
un outil que c'est un peu un adolescent
immature qui joue avec les institutions
qui s'amusent
il y a eu la représentation théâtrale où
il a joué pierre et le loup
il ya eu les rappeurs enfin un à deux
légionnaires en adolescent immature vous
devient peu ça il ya un peu l'idée d'
une surpuissance voilà il a eu une
élection très rapide et je crois que
cette élection lui a donné un sentiment
de surpuissance dont il use mais ce qui
est plus grave dans désormais je crois
il abuse